er singt über die liebe schicksal und
das glück kein corona in seinen songs
chinesischer hip hop in who an dem ort
wo alles begann hier in der konzerthalle
erinnern nur die masken anders corona
virus und irgendwie für trotzdem abstand
gehalten ein bisschen zumindest
wegen der panini konnten die sehr lange
nicht mehr solche live konzerte hören
ich bin total aufgeregt die menschen in
japan machen das was weltweit viele auch
gerne wieder machen würden unbekümmert
sein feiern
corona vergessen während der pandemie
hatten alle angst jetzt wird's besser
so klappt auf dem fischmarkt von wo hahn
infizierten sich zahlreiche menschen mit
dem corona virus die regierung versuchte
das ausmaß zu vertuschen wir fuhren nach
wochen auf der suche nach fakten und
fanden eine stadt im ausnahmezustand
[Musik]
überfüllte krankenhäuser bis heute gibt
es große zweifel daran dass die
offiziellen zahlen der korona kranken
und toten stimmen zwei tage nach unserem
3 wurde die stadt komplett abgeriegelt
elf millionen menschen im lockdown einer
dieser anwohner ist ja während corona
wurde er zum blogger zeigte seinen
familienalltag wir interviewten ihn
damals per handy aus seiner wohnung
mein sohn hat jetzt schon vergessen dass
es da draußen noch spielplätze gibt sein
erstes video wurde 30 millionen mal
angesehen
yangzom wurde hier von seiner frau
desinfiziert bevor er die wohnung
betritt die welt schaute damals nach
china auch wenn dieses virus sehr weit
weg schien in nur einer nacht haben wir
130 tausend follower mehr bekommen die
besucher ein jahr nachdem krone ausbruch
zu hause er empfängt uns mit seiner frau
und seinem kleinen sohn
die angst vor dem virus ist immer noch
da freiwillig blieb die familie damals
zwei monate länger in quarantäne
sie würden es immer wieder so machen das
vertrauen in die regierung ist nicht
groß genug
jetzt ist ihre größte sorge wie sie
finanziell überleben sollen
die epidemie hat große wirtschaftliche
folgen für uns alle
deswegen hat die provinz hubei
entschieden dass parks und
sehenswürdigkeiten kostenlos sind
das hilft uns hoffentlich denkt konsum
hier anzutreiben
die angst jetzt wäre eine zweite welle
das würden sie nicht schaffen finanziell
gleichzeitig sind sie stolz auf ihr land
stolz auf sich weil sie den lockdown
durchgehalten haben
man hat er schon sehnsucht nach freiheit
ich wollte einfach raus und dann hatte
ich auch kein einkommen mehr musste aber
jeden monat den kredit meiner wohnung
bezahlen
wir können weniger essen weniger geld
ausgeben einkaufen aber den kredit den
muss ich sein
im hintergrund das mobiliar aus dem
teeladen seiner frau der pleite gegangen
ist wie so viele kleine läden die in
china in keiner statistik erscheinen
janson zeigt uns sein geschäft er
betreibt eine fahrschule für
baggerfahrer das erste halbe jahr hat er
große verluste gemacht
eigentlich muss er immer die neuesten
bagger für die schule haben jetzt fehlt
ihm das geld
ich habe geld geliehen um zwei neue
fahrzeuge zu kaufen
seit februar konnte ich keine schüler
aufhänger lang und habe nichts verdient
zu lange hatte ich hier keine schüler
mehr dass man von heute hat viele
gesichter
für das land ist es die heldenstadt denn
die menschen haben hier überlebt das
virus den lock down
das ist auch die geschichte die sie in
einer ausstellung in johann den
besuchern erzählen natürlich ist hier
der chinesische präsident der größte
held
ihm widmet die ausstellung zwei räume
eine symbole die noch mal den
fürsorglichen staatschef zeigen soll
der kampf gegen korona und erfolg chinas
ist seiner die ärzte schwestern militärs
im gemeinschaftsgefühl und somit ist die
ausstellung für viele chinesen eine
patriotische pflicht die menschen in
rohan sind großartig und die chinesische
nation ist großartig
china hat das gut gemacht
johann ist auch die stadt der verlierer
die vielen kleinen läden und händler die
schließen mussten um das wirtschaftliche
überleben kämpfen und nicht teil von
chinas heldenepos sind johann ist die
stadt der vielen infizierten und toten
bei unseren dreharbeiten kritisieren
viele hinter vorgehaltener hand die
wirtschaftlichen folgen
wir treffen einen der sich allein
gelassen fühlt er hat als freiwilliger
geholfen unentgeltlich jetzt was er
nicht wie es weitergehen soll
ein kleiner angestellter von vielen der
angst hat und doch reden will
wir sind sehr wütend dass die regierung
nicht früher reagiert hat wir sind sehr
wütend weil sie das immer so machen sie
sagen das alles nicht so schlimm ist
dann vertuschen sie weil alle angst
haben was falsch zu machen ihren job zu
verlieren
jeder will seine reis schale füllen
das woran das wir heute sehen strahlt
und feiert seinen erfolg
und doch zeigen sich die risse die die
propaganda so sehr versucht zu
übertünchen
die angst vor repressalien war größer
als die angst vor einer möglichen
krankheitsfälle davon will china heute
nichts mehr wissen
das virus konnte eingedämmt werden weil
die regierung radikale londons
durchführte und auch das gehört dazu
die menschen haben zusammengehalten